are you ready for justin trudeau go talk
about meghan markle prince harry uh is
getting a lot of attention over his new
hairdo as he traded in the lock long
locks and beard for a trimmed haircut
uh
with a clean shaven face
[Music]
okay dope take that in take that photo
i am shooketh honey i am sugar was this
the
okay so oh okay we're gonna hold on to
this for a moment because i think we
just really this was okay so trudeau
debuted the new do over the weekend
while speaking with children during a
visit to chelsea quebec however his new
look immediately sparked comparisons to
one very similar the iconic bowl cut
rock by lloyd christmas lawhead mercy
aka jim carrey
in dumb and dumber
he went from justin bieber
to lloyd christmas
oh lordchild this is crazy why why did
he why did he do he has such beautiful i
know he makes money
oh he makes money he could have got this
done a little bit better i feel do you
think he did it himself maybe he did it
i don't know
i don't know but i just feel like
the image of somebody you know a
president or a prime minister they they
put a lot of effort into their image and
making sure that they look legitimate
that they look professional that they
look put together i mean the ones that
really care that's something that they
really sit there and think about every
single detail what color shirt to wear
after an incident when they do a speech
like all these things matter so whoever
did that cut don't like him
he upset somebody he didn't pay a bill
somewhere
because that hair care that hair care
looks like pure violence do you remember
when he first became the prime minister
he was the sexiest prime minister or
leader in the world do you remember that
do you remember that hair do you
remember right
yeah women were treating him like he
just won canadian idols guys like chill
out i know oh my gosh
oh that's so funny yeah but yeah you
have to be careful i i i hope his hair
grows back because i loved his hair with
the curliness and all of that it was
good i just the whole thing is tragic it
is god bless